Where I come from
respect for authority almost silenced us.
We are taught from a young age
never to speak back to elders
and especially those in positions of influence and authority.
But this is changing
and that’s all thanks to social media.
There is a young generation of Kenyans
who are using this space as a safe place for dissent.
Young people like me are watching in real
time
how the world around them
is surprisingly similar
and using online spaces
to create global conversations.
I remember hearing about officials in our
sports ministry
allegedly misappropriating funds
meant for our Olympic athletes.
Young Kenyans armed with nothing but hashtags
took to twitter and facebook and made their voice heard.
It was a perfect example of brotherhood,
nationalism and a call for accountability
140 characters at a time.
It’s really important for me
to listen to these emerging voices
of this young continent
and tell their stories.